if i'm going to make a video explaining
why it is that marvel's on the cusp of
losing spider-man and doctor strange and
a whole host of other characters
to probably never be seen in movie or
comic book form again
i'm going to need a shot of louis 13.
this is going to be an interesting video
okay so first things first we were going
to save this for the room around up and
honestly there's just so much to cover
here and the title is just so damn
clickbait we figured we might as well
make it his own video so what's actually
happening here okay so what's taking
place is that the estates belonging to
various chemical creators stan lee steve
ditko gene cullen among others are
filing lawsuits against marvel to take
back the copyright of the characters
that were created by these various
creators some of which have passed away
now the reason why this matters is
because if that were to happen it could
unfold in two different ways the first
is that they would be able to take back
partial copyright basically meaning they
and disney would share the rights to
these characters and essentially all
future proceeds the second thing that
could happen which is a lot more drastic
is they would get total copyright of
those characters in which case if the
marvel cinematic universe is going to
continue on marvel studios and disney
will actually have to pay them to use
these characters it's a pretty huge
thing now the reason why this is
important and the truth here is a lot of
people are talking about the copyright
act 1976 that's part of it but if we're
really being honest with ourselves this
all goes back to howard the duck so wind
the clock back to 1909 for a brief
second bear with me here back in 1909
with a copyright law as it existed back
then the idea is that if you had person
a making content for person b that
unless there was a clear contract
stating that person a was creating
content for person b as work for hire
then it was assumed that it was work for
hire now there were a few legal
precedents that were created in 1939 and
1965 by virtue of lawsuits but with the
copyright act of 1976
what this did is it basically said that
if person a is creating content for
person b and it's done as work for hire
there has to be a contract specifying
that more so than that if there's not a
contract that specifies that if person b
is spending money to allow person a to
create content for person b then person
b owns the rights to that character
right they're basically it's an expense
and that's the kind of deciding factor
when it comes to this now let's talk
about steve gerber and howard the duck
for a second so steve gerber of course
as you guys know and really just by
context here was a comic book writer for
marvel comics and also for dc the
problem is that he was basically fired
from marvel in the newspaper ships he
was writing at the time because he
couldn't meet deadlines but during his
time writing for marvel he created man
thing and he created howard the duck now
word had reached his ears in 1981 that
marvel wanted to license howard the duck
to create a film which as you guys know
they did and it turned out to be one of
the worst comic book films in the
history of
cinema like in general right but the
important thing here is that steve
gerber filed a lawsuit against marvel
comics to stop them from being able to
license out the film rights of the
character because he argued he was the
sole owner of howard the duck because he
created them now one of the big things
that happened here is yes there were the
clauses of the copyright act of 1976 but
one of the other things that marvel had
done and it was really cadence
industries who owned marvel at the time
is whenever they printed their checks
they had a little legend on the back and
what it said is that the person casting
this check acknowledges they're being
paid as work for hire basically marvel
owns the rights to whatever it is that
they're creating the fact that steve
gerber cashed these checks as far as it
was concerned from a legal precedent is
that steve gerber recognized that by
marvel's own expense he was creating
howard the duck i.e they were paying him
to create a comic book character
therefore marvel owned the rights to
howard the duck he ultimately settled
out of court and he acknowledged this
and that's the precedent that marvel
uses now the idea that's being kicked
around here right now is something
called the marvel method and that's what
marvel is using as this defense because
of the fact that people like stan lee
and steve ditko and gene collin weren't
just sitting in their apartments one day
and said i have an idea for a kid who
basically gets bitten by a radioactive
spider and then i'm going to basically
publish him under marvel comics but i'm
the sole original and only creator of
this that what you had is something
called the marvel method quite literally
you had comic book writers and artists
who would sit in an office called the
bullpen back in the 60s 70s and
partially during the 80s and they would
all basically just kind of spit ball
ideas together but the idea is because
they were working under the umbrella at
marvel in a marvel office and because it
was a collaborative effort among all
these different people all of whom were
performing work for hire by marvel or
for marvel that it was effectively
concepts created and owned by marvel
comics and so following that it was kind
of the standard that they used whenever
they argued those cases and historically
comic book publishers have won there's
never really been an instance where a
comic book publisher has lost the rights
to a particular comic book character
when i say a comic book publisher i mean
like the big two marvel and dc right
there is the legal case of jerry siegel
and joe schuster which was actually them
filing a lawsuit claiming ownership over
superman and it's one of the first
instances when this has actually
happened a kind of a creator filing a
lawsuit claiming copyright over the
character they created now in reality
they sold the rights to superman to dc
and in truth dc came along and basically
paid them a stipend afterward but that
was really more due to social pressure
because people learned that jerry siegel
and joe schuster were basically living
in poverty even though superman was just
like this enormous cash cow and so in
order to basically save face dc ended up
just kind of paying them a stipend for
the rest of their lives until they ended
up passing away but the important thing
here is that in every single instance
where a person or a creator has filed a
lawsuit against a comic book publisher
under the auspices that they own the
character that they basically created
the response of that particular comic
book publisher from the legal side
anyway is no this was work for hire we
paid you to create this character we
paid you to create howard the duck out
of our own pocket or we paid you to
create thor or iron man or black panther
or the mighty avengers or any of these
things regardless the company paid for
that character to be created therefore
under the copyright law of 1976 that
company owns that particular character
now whether or not these guys will
succeed i honestly have no idea only
time will tell but i will bet you this
disney and marvel will not risk losing
this just
multi-billion dollar slush fund right
that's just licensed to print money
they're not going to lose that and
disney's lawyers are nothing if not
litigious and they will comb over every
legal precedent they have to but i am
very curious to see how this ends up
unfolding because if they end up winning
this it'll totally change the landscape
of copyright law not just in relation to
comic books but just in relation to
print media and virtually all forms of
media where a person created something
even though it was done under work for
hire that's now being used by somebody
else even if it does balloon up and
become a multi-billion dollar thing
right but in any event we just wanted to
kind of break this down and explain it
to you guys give you guys a much better
idea of what's going on we'll post
articles and stuff down in the
description so you guys can read it for
yourselves but with that being said guys
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you